[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN: Good afternoon.
Hi, I'm Ben, the site lead.
And on behalf of Google
Arts and Culture,
I'm very excited to have Jamie
Bernstein and Clive Gillinson
here at Google New York
highlighting the West Side
Story Project, which was
created in partnership
with Carnegie Hall, the
New York Public Library,
the Museum of the
City of New York,
and the National Museum of
American Jewish history.
So 2017 is the 60th anniversary
of "West Side Story's" Broadway
premiere and is the centenary
of Leonard Bernstein's birth.
So Google Arts and Culture has
initiated this one-of-a-kind
project to allow audiences from
all over the world to explore
a truly great and timeless
work of art through thousands
of pieces of exclusive,
never-before-published archival
content, 25 rich, educational,
interactive stories,
and a groundbreaking
360-degree video
of the Carnegie-Hall-produce
performance of Riff's "Get
Cool, Boy" number.
So I imagine you all have
seen "West Side Story." yes?
You're all familiar with--
no, I got a no.
So well, you're in
for a treat then.
I found out about
it in 11th grade,
when my music
appreciation teacher
made the entire
class sing "America."
But more importantly,
more interestingly,
I learned in preparation for
this event that at one point,
the name considered
was "East Side Story."
And what a different production
that might have been.
Maybe Jamie and Clive will
tell us more about that.
So Google's inviting
audiences to dive
into the history and legacy
of the musical theater
masterpiece online.
Jamie and Clive today
are here to discuss
the evolution of "West
Side Story" over the years
and why its themes
remain so relevant today,
and the legacy of Bernstein
in his 100th anniversary year.
So let me tell you a little
bit more about our guests.
Jamie Bernstein is a narrator,
writer, and broadcaster
who has transformed a
lifelong love of music
into a career of
sharing her knowledge
and excitement with others.
She grew up in an atmosphere
bursting with music, theater,
and literature.
Her father, composer-conductor
Leonard Bernstein,
together with her mother, the
pianist and actress Felicia
Montealegre, created a
spontaneous, ebullient
household that turned Jamie into
a lifelong cultural enthusiast.
Inspired by her father's
lifelong impulse
to share and teach,
Jamie has devised
several ways of communicating
her own excitement
about classical music.
In addition to the
Bernstein Beat,
a family concert about her
father modeled after his own
groundbreaking Young
People's Concerts,
Jamie has also written and
narrated concerts about Mozart
and Aaron Copland, among
others, produced radio programs
and documentaries on a
range of musical topics.
And she's currently
at work on a memoir.
Clive Gillinson became the
executive and artistic director
of Carnegie Hall
in July of 2005.
He manages all aspects of
the world-renowned venue,
overseeing the teams
responsible for developing
the artistic concepts for
Carnegie Hall presentations
in its three halls, from
orchestral concerts to chamber
music, solo recitals to
jazz and popular music,
and wide-ranging music education
and social impact programs that
reach more than half a million
people annually in New York
City and around the world.
Clive considers
Leonard Bernstein
to be one of the greatest
influences on his musical life.
They worked together when
Clive was managing director
of the London
Symphony Orchestra,
collaborating on a number
of projects, including
the founding of
the Pacific Music
Festival in Sapporo, Japan.
Now, please join me in
welcoming Jamie and Clive.
[APPLAUSE]
CLIVE GILLINSON: Thanks.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Hello.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Hi.
Thank you-- oh, that was loud.
Thank you, Ben.
And wonderful to
be here and really
to be able to talk a little
bit about this extraordinary
project that we've put
together around "West Side
Story" in partnership with
Google Arts and Culture, who
have been truly extraordinary
partners in doing this.
I'd like to thank them very
much for what they've done.
And as Ben said, I mean,
this really relates--
the reason we got involved in
"West Side Story" at this time,
it relates absolutely
to the 100th anniversary
of Lenny Bernstein's birth, as
well as the 60th anniversary
of the first performance
of "West Side Story," which
is something that has
actually been part of life
around the world literally
since the first day.
I mean, I know even today,
there are performances going on
in several places around
the world every single day
of the year.
Now, as Ben
mentioned, I've always
felt that Leonard Bernstein
was one of the greatest
influences on my life.
I mean, he was certainly
the greatest conductor
I ever worked with.
And that was both as a player in
the London Symphony Orchestra,
but then subsequently,
as manager.
But just to give a sense
of the impact he had--
I mean, obviously, his career
here in New York was colossal,
but around the world as well.
And I remember talking
to a member of the Vienna
Philharmonic Orchestra when he
went there for the first time.
And for him, that was a
big deal because somebody
of Jewish origin going
there after everything
that happened in the war.
And it was a huge thing for him.
And apparently, you know, at
the beginning, he sat there.
And there was huge anticipation.
And he was sitting there,
and he couldn't start.
He was so nervous and uptight.
And he was sitting there, and he
just couldn't start the music.
And apparently,
the players said,
they were all looking at
each other and thinking,
oh, my god, this is going
to be a total disaster.
And then he started.
And within 10 seconds,
every one of them
was looking around
at each other.
And they knew this was going
to be a love affair for life.
So I mean, the impact
he had everywhere he
went was quite extraordinary.
That was just as a conductor.
He was also the greatest
music educator I've ever seen.
Obviously, a great composer,
a wonderful and versatile
pianist.
So his life, really, frankly,
was many, many people's lives
in one.
I mean, anybody would
have been thrilled just
to have lived one
section of his life.
I certainly learned many
life lessons from him.
And before we talk
about "West Side
Story" and this
fantastic resource,
I just wanted to explore a
few things I learned from him,
but particularly to hear
Jamie's view on them,
as a child growing up
with him as her father.
I mean, one of
the first things--
I mean, Einstein
always said curiosity
was the most important thing.
Curiosity is far more
important than knowledge.
And Lenny had an
insatiable curiosity.
He always wanted to be
better at everything he did.
Tomorrow had to be better.
And his view was that if you
couldn't do it better tomorrow,
you had failed.
And even at the age,
I think, of about 60,
he threw away all his scores for
all the Tchaikovsky symphonies
because he wanted to
study them all over again
without any preconceptions.
So Jamie, as a child growing
up in a household with somebody
with this unbelievable
curiosity,
seeking forever for perfection,
how was that for you
as a child?
And how did that impact on you?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Well,
it wasn't boring.
It was kind of an amazing
environment to grow up in.
And the thing
about my father was
that the curiosity
that you talk about,
it was a symptom,
really, of the fact
that he combined being
a perennial teacher
with being a perennial student.
For him, teaching and learning
were connected activities.
And he was a compulsive teacher.
Anything that he knew
and was excited about,
he felt compelled to share.
So as his kids, my brother
and sister and myself
were constantly learning things
from our father, whatever
it was, whether
he was remembering
a vaudeville routine
from his childhood,
or telling a Jewish joke, or
singing an ad from the radio,
or telling us about
Mahler's Fourth Symphony.
Whatever it was, it
was this compulsion
to share and
communicate the thing
that he was excited about.
And that's why he was such a
good teacher on television.
He did those Young
People's Concerts
with the New York
Philharmonic starting
when I was five years old.
And he went on for
over 15 years, I think.
There are more than 50 of them.
And he was an
amazing communicator
because he just had this
thing that reached out
to share his own excitement.
And that meant that he wanted
to learn as much as he could
about everything.
And then the minute
he learned anything,
he had to turn around and share
it with the person next to him.
So that's what made him
such a good teacher.
CLIVE GILLINSON: And
I always remember--
because we did a big project
with him, a Bernstein
festival in London in 1986.
And we had dinners every night,
of course, as he always did.
And the most extraordinary
people there.
And every single
person he sat next to,
whether it was a
nuclear physicist,
or a painter, or whatever, he
wanted to understand everything
about their life and
how their mind worked.
And I think what was
extraordinary for me
about him was he assimilated
everything as well.
It all became part of what
he understood about life.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Right.
And in fact, that
was his whole thing
was to break down the
barriers between genres,
or even to connect seemingly
unconnected topics.
And that was his whole way
of absorbing the universe
and then sharing it back
with everybody else.
So when it came to
being a composer,
he was mixing what we call
classical music together
with jazz and Latin
American music and blues.
And any kind of music
that entered his brain he
would absorb like a lint
collector in a clothes dryer.
And then and then
out from him would
come this music that
contained the lint from all
these other threads
and fabrics that he
had absorbed in his brain
CLIVE GILLINSON: I mean, tell
me a little bit about risk
as well.
Because I think one of
the lovely things somebody
once said to me about Lenny
was that he took huge risks.
And I mean, that meant sometimes
things went wrong as well.
But the fact is, he would
never take a small risk.
And the way they
personified it was to say,
if Lenny Bernstein was
going to fall off a ladder,
he would only ever fall off
the top rung of the ladder.
He'd never fall off the bottom.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: I think
Steve Sondheim said that.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Was
that Steve Sondheim?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Yeah.
CLIVE GILLINSON: OK.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: At
least when Lenny falls,
he always falls from
the highest rung.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Yeah.
So I mean, how was that
in your life as a family?
How was that personified?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh.
Well, as a dad, he was he was
pretty reliably affectionate
and always enjoyed our company.
I never felt unwelcome
in my dad's presence.
So that part stayed the same.
But as a family, we had to
go through his own career ups
and downs.
And that put a lot
of stresses on us.
"West Side Story" was a
giant success, of course.
But not every piece
of his was a success.
And in fact, his
biggest successes
were either before
we were born or when
we were really young as kids.
And then as we got
older, his pieces
became more complex
and more demanding,
challenging of the audiences.
And so they were often
met with ambivalence.
And so we, as his
family, experienced that
and had to live through that.
And it was
complicated sometimes.
CLIVE GILLINSON: I mean, Ben
mentioned at the beginning
that with the London
Symphony Orchestra
we created the Pacific Music
Festival with Lenny Bernstein
in 1990, which was actually
shortly before his death.
And he was already very sick.
And this was a project
to bring together
the most talented young
musicians around the world.
And obviously, it was
all about his teaching.
And we created an orchestra,
and he worked with them.
And when he arrived there, he
was already very, very sick.
And everybody was saying to
him, you've got to go home.
But he simply would
not, because he
wouldn't under any circumstances
let the students down.
And I mean, what
was astonishing was,
I mean, he'd struggle to
get up and even to get on
to the platform to conduct.
But the performances,
you would have
no idea there was
anything wrong with him.
Because the minute
he was in the music,
everything else disappeared,
and he was completely engrossed.
But he was asked there, a great
conductor, a great composer,
educator, pianist--
if you could only choose
one thing, what would it be?
And he said, that's easy,
to be a teacher, education.
Yes, I mean, that's--
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Well,
because it was like breathing.
So if you have to stay
alive by breathing,
then you would be a teacher.
Yeah.
And also by being a
teacher, that still
includes everything else.
CLIVE GILLINSON:
So what about his--
I mean, the conflict with
writing "West Side Story."
I think it was Koussevitzky,
his mentor, who
said to him, if you're
going to be taken seriously
as an artist, you can't write
any more musicals like this.
You've got to write
serious music.
For him, that must have
been a huge conflict.
Was it?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: It
was a huge conflict.
Well, back then, there was
really no one in the time
that he was coming up
who was crossing over
this way between
so-called serious music,
orchestras and symphonies and
that whole world, and Broadway.
And he was going back and forth
between writing symphonies
and conducting orchestras and
then writing Broadway shows.
So his conducting
mentor, who was
from the old country,
Russia and Europe,
and had the old-fashioned
way of looking at things--
and so he was worried that
his protege would lose respect
by continuing to write
for Broadway, that that
would somehow
disempower his protege,
or make him not be
taken seriously.
And he strongly
advised his pupil
to quit that Broadway nonsense
and stick to classical music.
Well, luckily, my father
was really not good
at following the advice
of authority figures.
He was always
finding his own path.
And there were many ways
in which that got him
in trouble at the time.
And even as a
symphonic composer,
he got in trouble, because
he liked writing tunes.
That's why he liked
musical theater,
because he liked writing tunes.
And in the middle 20th century,
12-tone music was the thing.
12-tone music meant
that you were not
allowed to write
melodies and you were not
allowed to write in a key.
So the music was
very intellectual
and thorny and challenging.
And you wouldn't
go home humming it.
So my father was perfectly
capable of writing
12-tone music.
And sometimes he did.
But he didn't want to feel
compelled to always have
to write that way.
But by writing tunes
in his symphonies
as well as writing
12-tone music,
he automatically
disqualified himself
from being accepted into
the pantheon of what
the academics in the music world
considered a serious composer.
He disqualified himself just
by insisting on writing a tune.
But of course, now,
who's got the last laugh?
Because his symphonies
and other symphonic
orchestral works are so great.
And they're so interesting.
And they're so
broadband, because they
have all these different
musical influences in them.
And they have real longevity.
Because now that
we are no longer
in this 12-tone
straight-jacket, his music
sounds great to our
contemporary ears.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Yeah.
I mean, it's interesting
that he knew that.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: I'm
not sure if he knew it.
He wasn't sure.
But he was just going to write
what he was going to write.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Yeah, see,
just had to be himself.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: That
was the decision he made.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Right.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
That was a big risk.
And he knew he was risking
his entire reputation
as a so-called serious composer.
But he was just going to
write the way he felt.
And now we're glad.
But there was no
guarantee for him--
CLIVE GILLINSON: Absolutely.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: --that he would
ultimately get that last laugh.
And he did not get it
in his lifetime quite.
CLIVE GILLINSON: No, I mean,
certainly the reviewers
looked down on music that
was tuneful, accessible.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
They mostly did.
They had bought into that
whole 12-tone thing too.
It was like a sort of
fascist musical state
that everyone lived in
the mid-20th century.
It's amazing to think back to
it now, because we're so not
that way anymore.
But in those years,
it was tough.
And as the musical director
of the New York Philharmonic,
my father was also
responsible for presenting
the young composers and
their new compositions.
And he was very serious
about really backing them
up and presenting
them and making
their music as accessible as
possible to his subscription
audiences.
And it was a challenge.
But he was devoted to
really supporting them.
It was a weird time.
CLIVE GILLINSON: So I mean, to
come on to "West Side Story"
now, which, in a
way, we've led up to,
I mean, certainly for me,
it's the greatest musical
ever written.
And what I love as well
is that for my kids,
it's exactly the same.
There's nothing
generational about it.
And as I said, it's
something that's
being performed around
the world every day
of every week, all the time.
And what brought it together,
really, and led to this Google
project, the Google
cultural project,
was the fact that
we were celebrating
our 125th anniversary at
Carnegie Hall in the 2015-16
season.
And we were trying to
think, what should we
do as our creative
learning project, which
is when we work with kids?
These are projects
where we work together
with a huge number of kids.
And they basically learn
a piece and to perform
in a piece that is
something that is normally
done by professionals.
And there are a few
professionals who
sort of help to build it out.
But we thought, what is
our dream of the one piece?
If we could just
choose one piece
to celebrate our anniversary,
what should it be?
And every single one of us
just said, "West Side Story."
I mean, it was automatic.
That is what it had to be.
And now, as Ben mentioned at
the beginning, it started out--
I mean, firstly, it was about 10
years in the making, wasn't it.
I mean, the team sort of
moved away from it in the late
'40s and only came back to it
again in the mid-'50s and was
going to be "East Side
Story" and about the Irish
and the Jews, rather than the
Puerto Ricans and white kids.
And it was all
about gang warfare.
And it was because gang warfare
was very much in the news,
I think, in the mid-'50s
that they came back to it.
But tell us a little
bit about the genesis
and why this arose again.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Right.
Well, yes.
The first idea of
"East Side Story"
was that it would take place
on the Lower East Side, which
was where there was
a big Irish community
and a big Jewish community.
And it was going to be all about
Jews and Catholics and tempers
rising over the Easter and
Passover holidays, you see.
This was the original idea.
But even back then,
the idea was that it
would be based on Shakespeare's
"Romeo and Juliet" and the idea
that the Romeo and Juliet
characters would come
from these two
different worlds who
were at war with each other.
So the first idea was the
Jews and the Catholics.
And somehow, they were
just not getting traction
with that idea.
So they shelved it.
And when I say "they," I mean
my father and Jerome Robbins,
who was the choreographer and
dancer himself, and Arthur
Laurents, the playwright.
So then Jerry Robbins,
or possibly Arthur,
read an article in LA
about how the Chicanos
were having street gang fights
with white street gangs.
And then suddenly, the
light bulb went on.
And he thought, well,
what if we still
made it happen in New York
City, but where there was
a big Puerto Rican population?
And so the street gang
could be Puerto Rican.
And the minute they
injected that new idea
of the Latin American
element, everything else
fell into place.
For my father, it meant
that all of a sudden,
he had this delicious menu
of Latin American music
to represent the Puerto
Ricans in the story.
The street gang was
called the Sharks.
So suddenly, all the
Sharks and the women
and the characters
on that side had
had all these wonderful
Latin American rhythms.
And then for the
Jets, the white gang,
my father used bebop jazz.
And so the music was
telling the story just as
articulately and energetically
as the words were.
And everything else
fell into place too.
The dancing, Jerry Robbins
could use Latin American dancing
for the Sharks and then use all
these different angular motions
for the Jets.
And the set design and the
costumes and the colors,
and everything just fell into
place with the Latin American
element.
CLIVE GILLINSON: So
just for a second,
tell us about the relationship
between Lenny and Jerome
Robbins.
Because I read once somewhere
that somebody said of Lenny,
there were only two people
that Lenny was scared of,
Lenny Bernstein was scared of.
And that was Jerry
Robbins and God.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: That's true.
Well, Jerry Robbins
was famously scary.
He was very intimidating.
He really bullied his artists,
his actors, and his dancers.
And he was famous
for being very mean.
And during the rehearsals
of "West Side Story,"
he actually segregated the cast.
And he said, all of
you playing the Sharks
and all of you playing
the Jets are not
allowed to speak to each other.
You are enemies.
And he created
this actual discord
in the rehearsal
process to encourage
them to find their
inner hostilities
for their performance.
And I mean, I don't know
if that worked or not.
But all we can say is
the show came out great.
So OK.
But yes, my father
was intimidated
by Jerry and by his temper.
And my father was the opposite.
They were like good cop,
bad cop in the rehearsals.
Because Jerry would
reduce everyone to tears.
And then they would all
go running to Lenny,
and he would make
them feel better,
and say, let's just
go around the piano
and rehearse this
number, and you're great,
and it's all going to be OK.
And he was made of love.
That's the way he always was
with everyone he worked with.
So somehow, in the
end, this combination
of bullying and love
seemed to work in the end.
CLIVE GILLINSON: And
when did Stephen Sondheim
come into the picture?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh,
yes, so Steve Sondheim
wound up being the lyricist.
Because originally,
my father was
going to write the
music and the lyrics.
But it was just too
much to take on.
And they were
running out of time.
And so they brought in this
kid, this 25-year-old kid, Steve
Sondheim, who was a protege
of Oscar Hammerstein,
as in Rodgers & Hammerstein,
who wrote "Oklahoma" and "South
Pacific" and "Sound of Music"
and all those really big
Broadway shows.
So Oscar Hammerstein's young
protege, very untested,
was recommended.
And they brought him
in as the lyricist.
And that all went
very, very well.
And frankly, I think it's a
good thing they brought him in,
because he's a much better
lyricist than my father.
He really was.
[LAUGHTER]
CLIVE GILLINSON: And the
issue of addressing openly
big social issues like
racism, gang warfare, all
of these things, plus a
musical that actually ended
sad rather than happy,
which was very rare.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Well, "Romeo
and Juliet" is a tragedy.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Yeah.
But I just wondered,
I mean, for him,
social issues was a central
part of who he, wasn't it,
addressing that.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Yeah, this
is such an essential element
of my father.
It's really the other big piece.
He was a conductor.
He was a composer.
He was an educator.
And he was somebody
who was always
trying to make the
world a better place.
And what worked best
for him was when
he could find ways to do
that through his own music.
And he did that
over and over again.
And "West Side Story" is his
most famous and successful
attempt, successful
attempt, to use his music
to explore the difficulties that
we all live with in our world,
and to use music as almost
a kind of healing process.
So in "West Side Story," which
is about hatred and intolerance
and fear of strangers arriving
in your neighborhood--
and these are all, of course,
issues that are as urgent
for us today as they
were back then--
my father's music
really gives us
a language with which
to explore these issues
and find our ways
to resolve them.
I think there was
a part of my father
that really believed
that if he could just
write a beautiful enough
tune and urgent enough piece
of music that maybe he
could heal the world.
I mean, he wasn't crazy.
He knew that was impossible.
But I think that impulse is
what really drove him forward
as a composer.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Right.
I mean, of course, he
never saw the project
we did a few years back that
is a centerpiece of this.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Oh, I wish he had.
CLIVE GILLINSON: I mean, I was
just interested in your take
on that.
Because all of this-- as
I said before, I mean,
this was done with
kids, most of whom
had never done dancing before.
They'd never done
any of the things
that we expected of them.
They ended up doing
a performance that--
I mean, I know I'm biased.
But even though it's
biased, I thought
it was the greatest
performance of "West Side
Story" I've ever seen.
And I'd love your take
on the whole project
and what lay behind it as well.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Well, that
performance was up there.
I'm really sorry my father
couldn't have seen it.
In his era, he was pushing
the technological barriers.
Back in the '50s, and for him
back then, that was television.
And television was
in its infancy.
And it was his amazing idea to
put his Young People's Concerts
with the New York Philharmonic
on television, which
allowed him to reach this
incredibly enormous audience
of people who otherwise
had never been exposed
to this kind of music.
So similarly, this "West Side
Story" at the Knockdowns Center
in Queens brought this
music to an enormous segment
of the population here in New
York City that otherwise would
never have been exposed to it.
So it was like taking
my father's opening
up of music to new
audiences through technology
to the next level
in the 21st century.
So he would have
been way into that.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Right.
So Jamie, I mean,
I've spent a lot
of time looking at
the "West Side Story,"
the digital presentation the
Google Culture put together.
I'm just interested in your
take, just on that exploration.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Well, it's magical.
I love it.
I haven't spent nearly
enough time yet exploring it.
You could really go back
to it again and again.
That's part of the
fun of it is that it
invites you to go back
repeatedly to explore
different parts of it.
It's like a big mansion
with different rooms
that you can wander around
in to your heart's content.
So I have to go back and visit
the mansion a few more times.
But I think that's what's
really cool about it.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Well, and
I think they have created,
or you have created,
they have created--
I mean, it's probably
the greatest resource
that's ever been created around
"West Side Story' isn't it?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh, for sure.
CLIVE GILLINSON: And it makes
it available to the world.
And I think when we put on
the project with all the kids,
I mean, one of our
incentives or motivations
was we wanted to put
a project together
that could be done by kids
anywhere in the world,
so to create a template that
meant everybody could do this.
And I feel this complements that
by really opening up "West Side
Story" for everybody.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Yes, well,
by putting it on Google,
that really does make it
available to absolutely
everyone around the world.
So what could be
better than that?
CLIVE GILLINSON:
So I just wondered
if anybody would like to ask
questions to Jamie or to me
either about "West Side Story"
or other things about her dad
as well, who is--
I can only reiterate.
I mean, I think he's probably--
"genius" is an oft-used word.
And it's used much too often.
I think he's the only person
I've met in my entire life who
I know is a genius.
There's lots of other people
people use the word for where
they're astonishing talents.
But that's not genius.
I mean, he was.
And so I think his impact
on the world of music
and so many other
things was colossal.
So I think there may well
be questions about him
people want to ask as well.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Any questions?
Go.
AUDIENCE: Should
we go to the mics?
CLIVE GILLINSON: There's
two standing mics.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
so much for coming.
And it was such a
fascinating talk
to hear about your father
and his inspiration.
I've actually never
seen "West Side Story."
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: What?
AUDIENCE: I know.
I just moved here.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Well, at least
watch the video of the film.
AUDIENCE: I will.
But I'm a huge fan of the
Philharmonic and everything.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: I'm
sure it's on Netflix.
Great.
AUDIENCE: So what
was his inspiration?
What was your
father's inspiration
for being, like, a
constantly curious person?
That's pretty rare
to find, especially,
I think, in someone older.
CLIVE GILLINSON: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: I mean, no offense.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Well, no, it's true.
A lot of people shut
down when they get older.
It's true.
AUDIENCE: And especially
when he was 60 years old,
he threw away
everything, which--
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Right,
the Tchaikovsky symphonies,
the scores.
AUDIENCE: So what motivated
him to be like that?
How was he constantly curious?
I don't know.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: I don't know.
I mean, to some degree, it's
just an accident of birth,
I think.
It's just the way
his engine ran.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Were
his parents like that?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Well, the other part--
this is what I was going to
also suggest as a possibility is
that his own father, Samuel
Bernstein, who escaped
Russia when the Jewish
people in Russia
were being butchered
in the pogroms.
He escaped at age 17 and
came to the United States.
And you know, the real
immigrant success story.
He managed to start his
own hair and beauty supply
business in Boston.
And got his whole family
through the Depression,
and was a successful
businessman.
But his passion in
life was the Talmud,
which is this gigantic
Jewish religious literature.
And he was a Talmudic scholar.
And his own intellectual
passion about the Talmud
was so profound that
maybe that somehow
was something he passed on to
his son, that kind of thirst
for knowledge, that
passionate curiosity.
So maybe my father observed
it in his own father
and emulated it.
That could have been part of it.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
CLIVE GILLINSON: I
think one of the things
I find fascinating-- when I look
at all the work we do in music
education, everything is about
trying to stimulate curiosity.
Because one of the things--
you both touched on it--
that forever is depressing to me
is the fact that you virtually
never meet a child who
doesn't have curiosity.
And you meet so many
adults who don't.
And I mean, the
terrifying thought
is that maybe our education
system is actually knocking it
out of them.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: That
is a terrifying thought.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Thank you.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Any other questions?
Oh.
AUDIENCE: So obviously,
"West Side Story," you're
saying it's being
performed daily
by different people in
different countries.
What do you see next for it?
Or is there any type of
performance it hasn't had?
I mean, obviously now,
it's in virtual reality.
It's been on TV.
It's kind of been everywhere.
But is there anything
that you would want for it
you that think your father would
like to see with this musical?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh, there
are actually many things
in the works, many things.
Well, the film from
1961, I think it is--
CLIVE GILLINSON:
I can't remember.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
--is much beloved.
It won 10 Academy Awards,
including Best Picture.
It's one of the most beloved
films that exist, especially
among filmed musicals.
But maybe it's about
time for a remake.
Well, guess who's interested
in remaking "West Side Story"?
Just take a wild guess.
What film director?
AUDIENCE: Lin-Manuel Miranda.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: No,
that's a good one.
But he's not a film director.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Right
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Spielberg, correct.
Steven Spielberg has
said that he wants
to remake "West Side Story."
So we're really hoping that's
going to happen very soon.
And that will
reintroduce the musical
to people who haven't
seen it in a long time
and will freshly introduce
it to a whole new generation
of people who don't
necessarily know it, like you.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's going to
be really exciting.
And there are also
all kinds of new ideas
for ways of presenting
"West Side Story" live.
So there are going
to be all kinds
of new theatrical
presentations being developed.
And then there's this
other fantastic way
to see the already
existing film.
And that is with live orchestra.
I highly recommend
it if you ever
see that it's being performed
that way in your community.
It happens a lot.
And it's quite a
technological feat.
Because apparently, the
dialogue and the music
were all on the same
track on the film.
But they managed, in their
infinite wisdom and magic,
to scrub away the orchestra
and leave behind the dialogue
so that a live orchestra
can actually accompany
the voices on the film.
And it's a really cool
way to see "West Side
Story," because the music sounds
amazing when you hear it live.
But then you hear
it with the film.
So that's also out there.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Well, and
the other thing I genuinely
hope is that partly because
of this extraordinary resource
that Google have
created and the way
it's opened up the possibility
of doing really broad education
projects with kids around
this-- because, I mean,
it is the most powerful
life-changing experience
that any kids we've
worked with have ever had,
working on that project.
And the thought that that could
be something that people can
experience, kids can experience
all around the world--
and there's no reason
they shouldn't.
I mean, I hope that
together, we've
all created a template that
enables it to be shared
in very different ways,
where people actually
participate, not just as
audience, but as participants
too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
interactivity is big,
especially with the
kids and all that too.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Absolutely.
There's another.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for being here.
"West Side Story" is one
of my absolute favorites.
I never tire of the music.
I've seen it countless times.
I have a two-part
question for you actually.
What you think drove your
father and the creative team
to tell the "West Side
Story" specifically
the way that they told it, with
such a strong social commentary
behind it.
They could have just
as easily written
a very beautiful musical that
was just the plain old classic
"Romeo and Juliet" story.
And then the second
part of my question
is, if they were to start from
scratch and make it today,
what two groups
do you think they
would have highlighted
as opposed to Puerto
Ricans and white people?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh, that's
a really cool question.
CLIVE GILLINSON:
That was very good.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Let's go backwards.
Let's do the second
question first.
I don't know.
If you were writing "West
Side Story," what would
your two gangs represent?
AUDIENCE: The alt-right.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Hmm?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: The alt-right.
Ooo.
That's a great idea.
And you know, there are lots and
lots of parodies of "West Side
Story" where they
do exactly this
and recreate "West Side
Story" with new groups,
new opposing gangs.
So I think the alt-right,
that would very interesting,
especially since, to go
back to your first question,
all three of the original older
creators of "West Side Story,"
Bernstein, Robbins,
and Laurents--
Sondheim was young, so he was in
a slightly different category.
But the three older
ones all came up
in the 1930s and early
'40s in this atmosphere
of left-wing,
liberal values being
very central to everybody's
experience in the United
States.
During the Depression
and Franklin Roosevelt,
there was this movement called
the Popular Front, where
all these left-wing
organizations were considered
to be very mainstream,
and everybody
was very plugged
into how this was
going to make the world better.
And socialism was a big thing.
And they were all very
interested in what
was going on in Russia.
And it wasn't until
a little later
that they discovered how
despotic and tyrannical
the Soviet Union actually was.
But for a while there, they
were very idealistic about it.
And so I think that their
whole leftism really
informed their desire to make
the world a better place.
They were really invested
in doing everything
they could to lift up audiences
and get them to think about how
to make their world
better and how
to overcome any kind of
prejudice or injustice
or hatred, all of
which was very much
in the fabric of
the United States
back then, as it still is today.
And that's why "Romeo and
Juliet" was the perfect vehicle
to use for "West Side Story."
And it's why this musical
never loses its urgency.
Because all those issues that
were so in the fabric of life
all the way back in
Shakespeare's day
are still with us today.
It's a little depressing that
we never seem to get past it.
But here we are all
these centuries later,
and these issues of hatred and
intolerance are still with us.
And so "Romeo and Juliet" still
speaks to us today, and so does
"West Side Story."
It's just as urgent as ever.
CLIVE GILLINSON: I'd be
interested in some of your take
on the issue particularly
about tribalism.
Because one of the things
that genuinely baffles me is,
I'd assumed that as
people get more educated,
tribalism would be
something that wane.
If anything, when you
look around the world now,
tribalism is actually more
powerful than it's ever been,
which is really disturbing.
And I have no idea
why that's happening.
I mean, whether it's about
people struggling for identity
or what it is.
But I'm just curious
as to whether you
feel some of these things-- you
know, what you feel about some
of the themes that are
really at the center of this,
how you feel they play today.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Anybody
have a thought about that?
AUDIENCE: I couldn't
say I would have
a succinct answer to that one.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
It's a big question.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Right.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: I sure
don't have the answer.
I mean, it seems as if we're
making progress and devolving
at the same time.
I mean, even if
you're all involved
in an organization
like Google, which
does so much to unite
peoples all over the world,
it feels as if that is an
enormous piece of progress.
And yet at the same
time, everybody
seems to be splintering off
into their own little groups
and becoming more tribal.
So it's as if we're going in
two directions at the same time.
And I don't quite know how
that's all going to shake out.
CLIVE GILLINSON:
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So the first
question is about Shakespeare.
So before watching "West
Side Story," the movie,
I also saw many versions
of "Romeo and Juliet,"
like in modern adaptions.
And none of them
really, like, got me.
They all seemed out of context
until I saw "West Side Story."
And it really struck me as
the best modern adoption
of "Romeo and Juliet."
So I am wondering how the
creative team got inspiration
from the original
scripts of Shakespeare.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Well, I think
they just read the play over
and over again.
And there is actually--
I think at the
Library of Congress
in my father's archives, there
is a copy of "Romeo and Juliet"
where he's written in the
margins all these ideas
that he's having.
So I think that they
just immersed themselves
in the play.
And the more they read it, the
more they thought about it,
the more they found
contemporary resonances.
But of course, it didn't
really come together for them,
it didn't crystallize
until they had
the idea of the Puerto Rican
gangs versus the white gangs.
That was the inflection
point when it all
came together for them.
AUDIENCE: The second
question is about the names
of the main characters.
How did they come up with
the name of Maria and Tony?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh,
that's a great question.
I don't really know the
answer to that question.
But my brother has
a friend who always
used to tease us by saying,
you know, I don't know why
in "West Side Story," when
Tony starts singing Maria
at the top of his lungs why
every window didn't open,
and every single woman
in the neighborhood
didn't stick her
head out the window.
Because of course, Maria
is such a common name
that you would think like 80%
of the women in the Puerto Rican
neighborhood would stick
their heads out the window.
So that was his joke.
But I don't know how they
chose those two names.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
the third question--
I'm just curious.
What's your favorite
score in "West Side
Story" if you have to pick one?
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh, my favorite
song, you mean, in the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Oh,
that is a tough one.
You know, it changes
all the time.
But I really love "Cool."
The music is amazing.
And I was talking before about
how my father would break down
barriers between genres.
So "Cool" uses bebop jazz, but
also uses an absolutely correct
fugue form, the way
Johann Sebastian Bach
did it all the way back
in the 1600s and 1700s.
So you're mixing a Bach
fugue with bebop jazz
and all these blues elements.
And it's amazingly
sophisticated.
And the dancing that Jerry
Robbins invented to go with it
is just so extraordinary.
I just think it's one of the
best things my father ever
created.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Thank you.
CLIVE GILLINSON: I'll
add a different one
for me, which is "Somewhere,
There's a Place for Us."
And I think it's one of the most
beautiful, simple, pure pieces
of music.
And I must have heard it a
hundreds of times in my life.
And I don't think
there's ever a time I've
heard it when I haven't cried.
And it absolutely gets
one both musically--
and it speaks--
I mean, again to quote Einstein.
But Einstein said, anybody can
make things more complicated.
The real skill is
making things simple.
And it's a piece
of music which is
so utterly simple and
so perfect that it
makes you weep every time.
But it also speaks--
"Somewhere, There's
a Place for Us,"
I mean, it speaks really
to, again, this whole thing
around identity and people
finding a place for themselves.
And it's the reason
why we chose it--
I mean, we actually called this
"West Side Story" production--
we built around it something we
called the Somewhere Project,
where we worked with school
kids in huge numbers,
where they developed
songs around that
and what it meant to them.
So I mean, that, certainly
for me, is the number.
But I mean, you said
it's your favorite piece.
Which is the one?
You know, "West Side Story" is.
So which number?
AUDIENCE: Probably I would
say "Somewhere" or "One Hand,
One Heart."
CLIVE GILLINSON: Right.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Yeah,
the "One Hand, One Heart"
is beautiful too.
CLIVE GILLINSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
my favorite one
is "America," because the music,
the choreography and the lyrics
were just so perfect.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Yeah, so perfect.
So I just saw a concert
version of "West Side
Story" with the Philadelphia
Orchestra in Philadelphia.
And when they sang
the song "America,"
there was no choreography.
Everybody was just
standing there doing
the music and the singing.
And when they got
to the line, "Nobody
knows in America Puerto
Rico is in America,"
Yannick Nezet-Seguin, the
conductor, stopped the music.
And there was this
gigantic deafening pause.
He stopped the music
so that that line
would resonate in the air.
It was right after
the hurricane.
And there was this incredible
silence in the hall.
And then everybody
went [GASPS],, yay!
[CLAPS]
It was very, very moving.
Whoops, excuse me.
It's so true about
the song, "Somewhere."
and Steve Sondheim's
lyrics really
speak to us now because there
are so many displaced people
in the world right now between
refugees and hurricanes
and fires.
And there's just so much
upheaval in the world
and so many people who are
looking for a place somewhere
to feel safe and peace
and quiet and open air.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when
I heard it, I thought,
this is still so relevant today.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN:
Yes, more than ever.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
CLIVE GILLINSON:
Well, I think it
speaks to the power
of "West Side Story"
that between us, just
at the beginning,
we've got four different
numbers that we all
think are the greatest.
And actually, we could
all choose any of them.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Yeah.
CLIVE GILLINSON:
Any other questions?
In that case, I think
from both of us,
it's a huge thank you to
Google Arts and Culture
for creating this resource.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: Thank you.
CLIVE GILLINSON: And
particularly to Amit Sood,
who was there right
at the very beginning.
I mean, he was the
one who loved the idea
and made sure it happened.
But I think it's a
project about something
we all love and all care about.
And to see that it's going to
be made available to the world
in a way that could never
have happened before I think
is very moving for all
of us involved, I mean,
particularly, obviously,
Jamie and her family,
but I think all of us.
Because music, really, is
part of a shared heritage.
So I mean, thank you to
Google Arts and Culture.
Thank you to all of
you for sharing with us
and for being here today.
It's been great to talk to you.
JAMIE BERNSTEIN: And
thank you, Clive.
CLIVE GILLINSON:
Well, and you, Jamie.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]